time to draft the people under the most
pressure this weekend week 16 is upon us
i've got the trivia question if big cat
gets it right he gets the first pick if
he gets it wrong i'll take the first
pick here's the question big cat jameis
winston has a chance to lead the nfl in
both touchdown passes and interceptions
this season only three players have done
that since the afl nfl merger in 1970
you need to name one and here's your
hint which i have revised to make it
even more fair to you one of them starts
for a current nfc playoff team
oh a current nfc playoff team
so would that be
drew brees
other ones eli did eli ever do it
eli did not do it
dang
bro the other ones you'll never get
you'll never get brett favre would have
been my first guess
brian sipe in 1979 and lynn dickey in
1983. those are the okay okay drew brees
did it in 2012. all right you get the
first pick all right my first pick i'm
gonna go with
the under pressure the mental toughness
of the san francisco ah here we go
again
again cause i called it last week i told
you last week we were sitting here in
this exact seat one week ago at this
exact time this is the one week
anniversary of me telling mike how
stupid he is the 49ers mental toughness
was on the hot seat last week because
they had that let down spot the falcons
came in and they won well guess what
it's back on my uh hot seat
this week
they have a short week they have a team
they know they have to win out to get
that one seed their mental toughness how
they bounce back is going to be
under pressure here and they should win
this game by a couple scores if they are
up for the challenge because i think
they're that much better than the rams
so will they be able to and this is a
big test mike because you mentioned it
if they they stumble here and then they
you know next week they have to go up to
seattle in week 17 you could be talking
about a team that looked like the number
one seed finishing the season
on a 1-5 1-4 stumble in the last five
games so their mental toughness is under
pressure and i have them winning this
game but it will be interesting to see
how they respond
it's amazing that your desire to troll
me on that point would supersede your
effort to have the best possible slate
of picks because you know i'm never
going to pick the 49ers mental toughness
you could have taken that in the 10th
round of a 10-round pressure draft we
could go 20 rounds and you would have
had it in round 20 if you wanted it you
don't have my other two picks either so
i'm good
all right this is one of those days
where big cat comes to the table with
all sorts of screwy non-conventional but
highly entertaining and somewhat
insightful picks i'm starting with
desean watson the first game out of the
gates tomorrow because everybody's
talking about jameis winston we're
fascinated by jameis winston what the
buccaneers can do and will they bring
back james winston how much they're
going to pay him here are the texans
they should win this game coming off of
a game that they did win that many
thought they would lose coming off of a
game that somehow they were embarrassed
at home against the broncos desean
watson has to prove to us that he can
will this team to win in a spot where
they're supposed to win there's been too
many letdowns this year from the texans
they have made a division that they
should have run away with far closer
than it should have been and look i know
he didn't have a lot of help around him
but when you're the guy who's the focal
point of the team when you're one of the
best quarterbacks in the nfl and he's
one of the three afc pro bowlers and he
deserves it he's that good it's on his
shoulders to make sure that this team
doesn't stumble again because somebody
in that organization is failing to get
it done and i think this is where watson
needs to lift that team himself
and will it to victory in a game they
need to have if they want to avoid a
week 17 elimination not well they could
make a missing playoffs altogether but
you don't want week 17 to be for the
division you want to nail it down and
they can do it tomorrow with a win over
the buccaneers it's on desean watson to
deliver it i like that pick uh the
texans they
they make no sense statement win
statement loss statement win makes you
think that maybe they'll have another
statement lost but deshawn watson can
stop that from happening okay my next
pick mike i'm going to go with the
patriots wide receivers you like that
pick is that a little more traditional
for you the buffalo bills are you know i
would say it probably goes patriots
49ers than bills for teams that are are
excel at coverage so it's going to be a
tough task for a unit that has not been
able to get separation for tom brady
we've seen the frustrated tom brady in
the press conferences on the sidelines
the patriots offensive line is also a
mess so yeah they might be under
pressure but it can be fixed if the wide
receivers to the patriots can find a way
to make plays get separation make tom
brady's job easier on saturday so i'm
going to say they are under pressure the
most pressure because how they play will
dictate who wins this game in my mind
and what you need to do this is what the
chiefs did a couple of weeks ago
because of the fact that tom brady made
it clear in the loss to the texans that
he was frustrated with those young
receivers double julian edelman double
james white forced tom brady to throw it
to the guys he doesn't fully trust yet
and that's the way that you can
potentially shut down the patriots
offense by shutting down the passing
game all right i'm going
hmm i'm going well you've already done a
49ers pick so i'm going to skip that one
i'll go for any kitchens look this is
the home finale for the cleveland browns
they've already beaten the ravens once
and this is more
don't get blown out right i don't think
the browns should go into this game
expecting to win if they win hey that's
great and maybe freddie kitchen's nails
down a second year but if they get
embarrassed right
the weird report last week from nfl
media that
management's inclined to bring freddie
kitchens back but
a horrific collapse to the end of the
season could cause them to change their
mind look they lost to the cardinals
team that had lost six in a row there
was the report of the players saying to
the cardinals after the game come get me
kareem hunt comes out and says we got
guys who don't kick it in until the
second half that's an indictment of the
head coach he's the one who needs to
have these guys ready to play from the
moment the game starts if they get blown
out by the team that used to be the
cleveland browns i think that's it for
freddie kitchens it may already be it
anyway but if he has any hope of
sticking around he's got to deliver on
sunday against the ravens not
necessarily with a win but a one score
game that could be the thing that gives
him at least a chance to get a second
year in cleveland it's crazy that we're
even having this discussion when what
you just said is true that there are
multiple players on the browns that are
going over to the other sideline and
saying please come get me i mean
how how how are we even having this
discussion that freddy kitchens is gonna
remain the coach um all right good pick
good pick
how about let me go with
the hot seat bowl the hot seat bowl in
atlanta
somehow someway mike dan quinn
has sort of kept his jobs job alive matt
ryan has come out and spoken in his
favor the the locker room has responded
they've beaten the saints they've beaten
the 49ers which was a huge letdown game
for the 49ers last week that most people
with the brain saw coming
this is a game doug marone is also on
the hot seat whoever wins this game i
think will be able to keep their job and
the loser of this game is going to be a
little bit deeper water so to speak so i
can't believe we're talking about dan
quinn possibly having his job next year
but it feels like if they win this game
and they win you know week 17 i think
they're playing the bucks
um he might keep his job
it's crazy it's crazy mike he might keep
his job
there's a weird sense that i've gotten
this year that arthur blank the owner of
the falcons doesn't like
the idea that fans and media are telling
him what to do right there was a
groundswell that quinn should have been
fired during the bye week and blank was
determined not to do it and and i just
feel like he's exercising the
billionaire's privilege to do whatever
the hell i want to do and the fact that
you people want me to do something else
means i'm not going to do it and look
there's a strategic reason to keep quinn
around they're going to have cap trouble
next year it's not like a new coach can
come in and make a bunch of changes the
the new coach would be stuck with a lot
of the players that dan quinn wants to
have there anyway and it could be that
you have a hard time finding a coach
that will choose to come to atlanta
knowing the cap problems they're going
to have next year and that that you know
if hey you may not believe in matt ryan
well too bad you're going to have to
coach him for at least a year so i think
that that helps quinn beating the 49ers
in santa clara helped beating the saints
in new orleans helped and if they can
finish strong this year there is a
chance quinn comes back i think marone's
safe either way though my last pick is
anthony lynn the chargers head coach
they were embarrassed last week at home
seven turnovers at a certain point it
speaks to the amount of discipline and
accountability the players have you
can't put the ball on the ground or
through the air into the other players
hands that often and not have it reflect
on coaching and and
every year
there's a coach who gets fired that when
it happens it's a surprise and of course
if we start talking about it then it's
not a surprise
but i was told over the weekend the guy
to watch this year
potentially is lynn and it's it's i
don't think it should i i would be
opposed to it
they were 12 and 4 last year
but with the chargers having all these
issues and getting a fan base in la and
you know they're constantly dealing with
the rumors of possibly moving i i just
feel like that that frustration
everything they're dealing with all the
crap that is constantly falling on that
franchise what can you really do
to spark your team into the next year
you're not going to sell it yeah i guess
they could fire their gm while they they
gave tom telesco an extension earlier
this year
anthony lynn is
one way to stave it off is to not
embarrass yourself and your team against
the raiders and you know that raiders
fans are going to take over that stadium
and what will be the last game the
chargers ever play there they lose that
game
and
it may be that that's the name that
comes out of the blue on next sunday or
monday that people are surprised by and
maybe they shouldn't be and what do we
say every single year about the charges
it seems like for the last five six
seven years they're always they either
make the playoffs we say watch out for
the chargers they have a talented roster
or they miss the playoffs we say how did
that team miss the playoffs they have so
much talent on their roster they lose a
bunch of really close games and it seems
to happen every single year so that was
they were in that off year in the in
that cycle where they don't make the
playoffs but they have a playoff caliber
roster and they lost a few very close
games that kept them out of the dance
hey they should have won last week they
were up 12 to 10 in the or no it was oh
no it was 10 to 9. wait vikings were up
12 to 10 that's what it was and the
chargers had the ball they had gotten an
interception of kirk cousins on a screen
pass chargers could have taken the lead
going into half they have that that that
weird play with the reverse holy roller
and uh the next thing you know the
vikings are taking the ball 80 yards the
other way for a touchdown and it just
opened the floodgates they could have
and should have won that game and how
many games this year for the chargers
can we say they could have been should
have won i think every game they lost we
can say they could have and should have
won
yeah it's uh it's crazy like that you
know and then they go and the the
packers might you know are still alive
for the one seed and remember how they
just absolutely pasted them so 26 to 11
down yeah it's an up and down season for
the chargers again and it feels like
that always happens and what happens
when when you underperform to the
caliber of your roster it's usually the
coach's job
and also they they have to get a fan
base in la and uh that that may be the
thing that forces change as well we got
to take a break
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports